nine over four who agrees with that is a
gradient 91 yes thumbs up
thankfully we have all the working fear
only thing that I would do reprove this
is equal sign going vertically otherwise
it looks flawless to me can you see you
know minus nine minus four more
so they're both make it is and then just
going to cancel or leaving it as am
vegan is a complete rule is also fine
nothing specifying the call they run it
so you go to the three one one line y
plus four X plus 2 now the answer is no
but my question to you is how do you
know that how would you explain or argue
and to why why would you say the line
ok so I think you're trying to appeal to
a picture right when you say the wait is
deadly
- by the way what would you say - like
what makes you just able to read that
off and not do any work or anything like
that because usually to find the way to
50 after winning 4-0 and let X equal
zero why do you have to just read it off
you say so you recognize this ball you
may get quite good at recognizing once
you can see me like I don't that mean
so you've got an intercept there with 3
comma 1 where would that go 3 comma 1
well that's like 1 1 2 3 or B there
wouldn't so the goods maybe no fishing
you hit you like wait a second why is
that the two integrating all which means
it's sort of ok so it's not even going
close is it
okay however I could have quite easily
change the coordinate I think they put
them here and it's not so obvious
anymore so how can we actually not just
look at it and say I think you actually
prove this the lot line on this line
what could we do
would you say
okay so this is the pads pear-port it's
an X comma Y and this is X and this is y
if they are on the line that means I
should be able to put this in and it
should work right but what happens when
you don't let's actually test out when x
equals three that's a value here I'm
going to put it into the right-hand side
what do you get 4 times 3 is 12 plus 2
is am I supposed to get 14
I'm in trouble this is telling me I
should get one it doesn't work ok so the
fact that this is not equal to each
other means don't work with the equation
very good you've made the 10 all right
last one and then on one into question
what can I do this what do I need for
general form is a few different
characteristics with very ok so I'm
going to can't everything over first so
that looks like this by the way why did
I am subtract these two things in
different butterflies when I subtract
they're in different spots why name is 1
for water yeah generally doing a
statically right X's and then wise and
then your other side I'm up by there
what else do I need to do okay so how do
I do that
[Music]
what's the in this way to change all the
signs to be applied I'll multiply by
negative one right thank you some gifts
it's fun it is a fuzzy now but I'm still
were in general for what's missing
somebody hasn't said anything
yeah so I want to suggest what missing I
know you didn't I want to see clusters
deep in some thank you okay so a B and C
they're fractions at the moment I want
whole numbers so what should I do it
there's something I can do with one go
don't took everything into integer now
multiply by three is it good first step
it'll get rid of business school will
get rid of change it to a new job but it
won't change this Willa we drink waters
through what was the most three and four
same time which is 2012 that should get
rid of everything right so let's do no
12 times this 12 times then and what's
times five cool I've run out of space
down here but you can do the final line
cut you twelve divided by three with
that for the boss spot by two and a
that's how many X's here twelve divided
by four
that's how many Y's and then you've got
to hang out the again you happy